Tencent is a Chinese investment holding conglomerate with many, many, many subsidiaries.
They include social networks, payment systems, media, entertainment,...
...smartphones, e-commerce, property, advertising,...
...and there's still more.
The company's stock is up more than 11,000 percent...
...since it went public in 2004 on the Hong Kong Stock Exchange.
And if you've ever said the words,...
"Wouldn't it be nice if there was an app that could...?"
Chances are, Tencent already has it.
At the center of the giant conglomerate is one app,...
...Weixin, known as WeChat outside of China.
Think of it like a Facebook meets WhatsApp,...
...meets Venmo, and Candy Crush, and Tinder, and Amazon.
And there's still other functions like booking a doctor's appointment,...
...or finding out how densely crowded a location is.
The number of people on WeChat is now closing in on one billion users.
Tencent has acquired and invested in so many companies,...
...it's almost impossible to figure out where it starts and where it ends.
First, there's the social networks.
In addition to WeChat, there's QQ,...
...with more than 861 million monthly active users.
For some perspective, that's more than Instagram.
Then there's the multiple digital payment platforms it claims...
...and WeChat Pay may be its first foray outside of China.
Entertainment is also a big part of it.
Tencent is actually the biggest computer game publisher in the world,...
...bigger than US game publisher EA Arts and Activision Blizzard combined.